we're out here on the streets of
Hollywood asking people how much they
know about their favorite music the
first we got to talk to people with
headphones in typically those people
don't want to talk excuse me excuse me
sir cheese me no okay we're gonna get
him to talk what kind of music you
listen to um this is the pearlescent
album the movie was shared Schaller
right now I'm listening to the weekend
weekend that's why that's a good you
shouldn't be embarrassed about that he's
great what music are you listening to I
was into a band called death how much do
you know about yeah
um quite a bit yeah I feel like if I
were to is you you could nail it
hopefully okay Christina Aguilera she's
great
do you know where Christina Aguilera was
born I'll even google it I'll Google
while you guess where do you think
Christina Aguilera was born think of
some context clues like Christina
Aguilera
she's like a blonde do you know where
the weekend is from Canada yeah girl so
Christina Aguilera was either born in
Kentucky New York or Florida which would
you guess
I said Kentucky Kentucky you're wrong
it's Staten Island New York I mean who
would know that so who is your favorite
country artist a Hank Williams jr. Hank
Williams jr. I definitely a great choice
do you know how old he is he'd be right
now probably about 71 71 that's a little
over 67 not bad they're all pretty close
so you're just listening to some music
right there right yeah what were you
listening to Mandy Moore oh maybe more
yeah Wow was she up to this isn't the
question this is just me okay what was
Mandy Moore's first big single uh-huh
that's so hard candy you're good like
that's it it's crazy yeah good you know
who do you listen to the most that's not
like a DJ I like a band
MF DOOM is it mother dude yeah
okay I listen to slander EDM who are the
members of slander the members of
slander yeah Eric Adam you wanted like
Eric Adams right it's Derrick Anderson a
very close and then Scotland Oh
which never been there sounds like a
beautiful place though Scotland solid
red of all I don't know how you would
know that but Google knew so huh good
one happy that's just the truth now you
know that I think we're more informed
yeah thank you for the information
thank you for appreciating the
information what's your other favorite
band Megadeth Megadeth yes sing in the
same death beam